ينضم الينا من عمان لواء فايز الدويري
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي اهلا بك معنا
سياده اللواء ما الذي يعنيه بالنسبه
لمليشيا فاجنر الوصول الى بخموت والسيطره
عليها اذا ماتم
يعني هي اولا تسجل ما يطلق عليه قدم السبق
وتحقق ما عجز عنه الجيش الروسي الجيش
الروسي عجز عن السيطره على السوليدار التي
تقع على شمال الشرقي
والان وبالتالي
نجحت فاجنر في بعد ان اخفق الجيش والان
نتحدث عن
الركن الاساسي وحجر الزاويه في
الجبهه الوسطى والسيطره عليها يعني كبعد
معنوي على الاقل الشيء الكثير من الذي
حققته فاغنر وبالتالي هذا
يحفز ويعطي مزيدا من التحفيز لقائد فاجنر
الذي لم يتورع عن انتقد بمنتهى الحده وزير
الدفاع ورئيس الاركان وبالتالي قد يعزز
اوراقه في الوصول الى منصب وزير الدفاع
مستقبلا اذا
اذا اردنا ان نفهم ايضا التباين في
المعسكر الاوكراني ننسحب لا نريد ان ننسحب
تصريحات عديده من الميدان ومن قبل
السياسيين ما الذي يعنيه بالنسبه للمعسكر
اوكرانيا
اعتقد ان هذا الخلاف قد حسم قبل 48 ساعه
عندما صرحت نابت وزير الدفاع وزير الدفاع
الاوكراني ان قرار المعركه انيط بالقاد
العسكريين الميدانيين وقلنا منذ ذلك الوقت
ان القرار سيكون قرار انسحاب لانه من وجهه
نظر عسكريه
باخمت في حكم الساقطه ولكن فاتوره
التكاليف ستكون اكثر ايلاما لجانبي الصراع
سواء الجانب الروسي او الجانب الاوكراني
لكن الجانب الاوكراني بما انه هو الخاسر
في هذه المعركه فعليه ان يحتفظ بما تبقى
لديه من قوات
لتوظيفها في تعزيز الخطوط الدفاعيه التي
بدا بانشائها منذ اكثر من شهر
يمكن ان يتمركزوا للدفاع اكثر وعدم خساره
اراضيها اخرى
باختصار بدا الجيش الاوكراني بدا الجيش
الاوكراني منذ اكثر من شهر في بناء اكثر
من خط دفاعي في المنطقه التي تقع امام
سلافيا كراماتوريسك لانها هي المدن
الرئيسيه وسقوطها يعني سقوط ما تبقى من
دونسك وبالتالي انا اعتقد ان المعركه
الحاسمه والمعركه القويه لا اقلل من معركه
فاجنر ستكون في الخطوط الدفاعيه شكرا التي
تقع الى الامام من دونيسك وسلافيانوس فايز
الدوير الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي من
عمان شكرا جزيلا لك